would the economy have to get before you
view a second income and a relationship
as a necessity
to the point where I can't afford no
kitchen rule
I I feel like I would have to be let go
from my job and like dismissed from my
family and like out on the street
somewhere for me to be asking somebody
like hey can I rely on your income too I
just and maybe I'm just too independent
for that but like it's it's a joint
income though it's not you don't have to
like get to the to the to the very end
of the road before you sit in there and
say hey we could have a better life yeah
if we pool our finances yeah it's like
if you make 40 and they make 40 That's
80. So then you have half the round you
just have to you just have to like you
know agree sometimes even if you don't
feel like agreeing you know you know
it's no I don't want to come on I want
to be homeless on the streets
please sir have you got any change
um okay what about you oh god
um yeah I'm gonna probably align with uh
Kia I
I would
rather just like get like a roommate
then compromise like under like I would
rather get a roommate or two roommates
before I went to being dependent or
having a part of my life being dependent
on someone else's income and like a
romantic setting okay that just would
make me really uncomfortable so you'd
rather have roommates than a man I'd
rather have roommates than depend on a
man in a real like I would rather
there's no I would rather yeah have
multiple roommates yeah it would take a
long time to depend on the roommates
though yeah but that's a contractual
agreement like being in a relationship
like the only way that I would do that
is if I was like married or like we were
working towards marriage I wouldn't just
have my livelihood be intertwined with
someone who wasn't my husband or Gonna
Be My Husband okay okay what about you
so I definitely think it's easier when
you pair up with someone in terms of
like staying with them and stuff because
it is really expensive nowadays in
London especially I'm from London so I
don't necessarily think that for me at
my age I'd want to pair up with like a
man per se but family like roommates
friends Etc I'll definitely let that be
down for it because the living costs are
really bad at the moment like it's and
the income's not Rising with it so it's
just it's not really making much sense
but yeah this is just not there
um but yeah I definitely be open for it
but I also think as well that just
for people that are like aware of the
conditions just really trying to figure
out how you can bring in more income at
this point because I just don't think
like a job really can sustain people at
that or just one job yeah multiple
streams one income now is just not gonna
sustain people
I'm just not gonna lie okay what about
you um for me personally I have family I
have my dad I have uncles I have family
but what I will say is down to money
management and being aware of your
income what you can spend what you have
to expend with the cost of living like
for me I have a spreadsheet so I can see
how much things have gone up so that
means I can restrict I've always lived
by myself I've never had roommates I
don't have roommates now so you know not
everyone is fortunate enough to have
family
um to rely on a man who is not your
long-term partner that's risky risky
yeah and if it goes sour you still end
up he could be your long-term partner
you can make it worse
what if it goes right
but I'm saying like if you're just
moving in from living by yourself or
living with friends to live with a guy
to rely on him for rent or whatever
that's kind of
isn't this how relationships used to be
families men and women used to get
together and rely on each other to build
a family build a household potentially
build a stroke a stable enough
environment to have kids in like I don't
understand how we move so far left from
that that you'd you would rather be
homeless on the streets you would rather
rely on on on people to live with you
that you don't actually know that could
move out with their boyfriend at any
time no I do I do know them for sure
it's like if it's it's I think it sounds
more like everybody's just scared to toe
the line I mean I don't I'm gonna push
back on that because like okay how
things used to be yeah people used to
also be an extreme really toxic
situations like we're also this
generation we're all half of us are
child's Children of Divorce or why the
relationships that should have been or
should be divorced so I think with
having that awareness of like what could
go wrong living what could go wrong yeah
we're gonna be so much more we're gonna
live in a fair though yeah I don't think
that's fear I think that's being smart
you know what do you know what the shift
came from the shift came from after like
the second world war right before the
second world war that everybody had like
this sense of Duty a sense of community
a sense of responsibility as soon as the
war was done everybody was like we're
liberate we're free we want go out and
chase your dreams be happy do whatever
you want to do two generations later you
got people chasing happiness that don't
even know what makes them happy and now
we have no sense community no sense of
togetherness and this is kind of why
we're in this situation now where we're
afraid to just realize that we all kind
of need each other I disagree with that
okay why do you disagree because we can
still have a sense of having a sense of
community isn't contingent upon having a
romantic partner well those two things
are not like that's where the community
starts because that's where your home
starts a romantic relationship is where
your home starts so okay so if you have
I have a question I have a question what
would you rather have at 60. a husband a
roommate or live with your parents well
obviously I would rather have them like
I mean obviously I'd rather have a
partner like my husband however that
doesn't mean that I'm willing to
sacrifice I mean you must live in a nice
house boy because she's like I ain't
sacrifice I mean I do I do I do pretty
well for myself
yeah but I'm not I mean but I yeah maybe
that is my privilege maybe I should
check my privilege that I haven't yeah I
I have I've been very fortunate I have a
really good job I I'm a content creator
I make extra money on the side as well
so like I can't fathom a possibility
of my life going that way and so I think
it is because of that privilege that
that will shape my perspective
um so maybe I should take a step back I
have a question
um out of everyone here who has six
months of expenses covered if you were
to lose your job tomorrow so you do
um
six okay that's good
not half
I don't know it's so one wait raise them
high raise them high so one two three
four five that's decent half that's like
more than I thought like we would have
what sounded a living though like
because I'm gonna have to cut all the
way back by month six but I'll be here
whatever your standard of living is now
yeah yeah that's the same muscle beans
are still good
um so have you guys had to make any
changes to your spending habits in the
past six months
oh definitely not not really yeah let's
take away
mine is cooking in the yard now I mean
look sad
and has and has your job industry or job
prospects changed drastically since 2022
or in 2022
anyone yeah well I I'm a tattooist by
trade so my my clientele fluctuates
throughout the year of the summer time
preparing for summer time everybody
wants to you know get their tattoos done
but then times like now coming into
winter you know they have more
um different obligations and and
different avenues for their finances to
go down so yeah this is this that winter
time is my time to chill out hence why
I've spent so much time with my other
projects
um so yeah I think everybody's feeling
like that at the moment
anyone else anyone well you mean what
like have you guys had layoffs at your
companies I've had layoffs at your
company what do you what do you work as
you said a content creator well well
that's like on the side this is on the
sidewalk and I'm I work in the tech
industry so I'm a Management Consultant
oh okay so tax it's been hit hard and
time yeah
yeah and then I have friends who have
friends who are Amazon or friends who
are Twitter none of my thank God so far
um none of my friends have been laid off
but
uh I have a lot of people like that are
all most of my immediate circle are in
the tech industry as well so it's a
tough topic yeah it's not affected the
entertainment industry for me anyway
there's still films being made so it's
about whether you get a job as an actor
or not so it's even more auditions now
yeah I feel like it's allowed people to
like think smarter into their like
investment choices so obviously before I
would work and spend money and just buy
useless stuff yeah like oh I want the
new iPhone that's coming out this year
so I'll get it and then obviously when
you get hit by something such as like
the cost of living crisis or a pandemic
it allows you to think okay how can I
think smarter and make money that will
generate wealth and do certain things so
for me I've looked into stocks and
trading Isis and kind of trading and
doing stuff like that that will I can
put my wealth into something and then
flip it and generate more and then keep
on doing it so some things it's not
immediate yeah you know sometimes people
invest things into things that will get
them immediate gratification sometimes
it doesn't work like that but in 10
years I can say wow I've managed to put
a certain amount of money no matter how
much it is and flip it and in 10 years
time I can look into that and be like
wow at least I invested and now I can do
something else generate and like work in
something like property or whatever it
is I can invest that into something else
and flip that and I think that's really
important like with my generation
especially is
material objects they're not going to
last forever you can have the newest
Louis pouch but if you don't know how to
invest and kind of invest into your
future sometimes it won't last sometimes
you might be really lucky and managed to
do everything but I feel like sometimes
you have to look at things in a bigger
picture when you're younger and it will
help you manage to do it when you're
older and then you if you look at past
examples made by family members or
something like listen to your family
members because whatever they're telling
you you might think at the time oh that
talking like whatever but then when you
look at back in 10 years time you'll be
like wow my family really tried to set
me up for generational wealth and tried
to really help me get money
opportunities because they can see
things that you won't even see happening
yeah and I think that's really important
like yeah like my family were the ones
that taught me about generational wealth
and just being invest well and invest in
things that will make you profit and
help you in the future so maybe not
right now but in the future that will
definitely be an investment I'll look
back on and be like I did that or like
I feel like you're really fortunate to
like have family members who are able to
like guide you in that sense because I
feel like a lot of parents do not
necessarily know how to guide their
children in like the modern world today
especially like with everything rising
and just this different environment
nowadays and I agree that
now for me personally I'm much more
cautious when it comes to what I'm
spending my money on now and obviously I
work a part-time job but I'm just
the same opinion there was like you
might want to get that thing or spend it
on that expensive shoe or whatever it is
that interests you material
materialistic things really are much
more like sensible now I'm thinking okay
I can spend my money on that but
maybe the budget and thing that you were
saying that dividing it into a sense
where it's like okay I'm going to put
that for that and put this down for
investing in my future investing in
myself in whatever form that is like you
said cryptos and stocks and stuff it
could be invested in your business
whatever it is like even if you want to
be like on social media content creation
whatever invest in them in that just in
yourself and whatever you want to do and
set yourself up for where you see
yourself in the future just so that when
you're at a particular obviously I'm
quite young but when you're at a
particular age you don't really want to
be struggling how people are struggling
you know what I mean like or if you've
got parents as well that struggle to
like raise you and stuff like you don't
want to repeat that in your family or in
your in your generation or whatever so
you're trying to like work 10 times
harder to make sure that you don't
repeat just family classes and to a
degree you know I mean I feel like it's
much more prominent now for people to be
cautious of not everyone but they are
like probably in my circle just a large
amount of people who are very cautious
of that and thinking ahead and thinking
in the future which I think is very
important extremely important to do so
if you're young it's like for me I think
it's the best years for you to even
think about your future a lot you
shouldn't really be wasting it on like
things that are just gonna go do you
know what I mean like sustain sustain
make sustained decisions
yes louder but also I feel like would
you sorry no go ahead oh would you argue
that like things such as covid and
everything play the factor in your
mindset now and how you think obviously
because kovid obviously loads of people
would have been made like redundant
would have been laid off and obviously
it made you think sometimes about your
mindset and it allowed people to like be
like wow okay so I can't work at this
current time or furlough and everything
yeah so how well will I cover the
difference that I'm losing I think for
me it's more of a personal reason as to
why I'm like ambitious I'm motivated and
just dedicated to making those changes
for myself but I agree with the common
situation like I was one of those people
who was a victim of it like I lost my
job I had a certain amount of money that
I was just having to live off and it's
like it's just deducting deducting and
there's no more gains because obviously
I lost my job and I was one of those
people so I guess it's like to a degree
that could have impacted my mindset and
I just decided to believe that okay it
anyhow you could just lose your job
nowadays and then what you're gonna do
do you know would you would you say
you're extremely Frugal now what do you
mean by Frugal like that means not
spending a lot of money
um right now yeah I'd say so I'm very
cautious of what I spend nowadays to be
completely honest with you how do you
have your nails done then
um
that wasn't her money
it was literally my birthday
yeah it was two weeks right it's not
really get your nails done if you want
to get yourself
it doesn't matter
that is an investment in you girl I have
nothing against women getting their
nails done it just didn't sound like
what you were saying yeah yeah I hear
your point but it's like at the end of
the day you couldn't put money down for
certain things that you like to enjoy
I'm not gonna restrict myself and be
living a certain way just you know what
I mean like you put your money down for
that you also put your money down for
that and that's fine obviously it's my
birthday I do like to look nice spend
money on my appearance I'm a woman at
the end of the day like this is a very
important thing so as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation help helps and it helps
make what we do possible